صعيد المتصل افادت صحيفه الجاردن
البريطانيه ان قوات امريكيه وبريطانيه
تنقل بالقرب من السودان وسط تكهنات
متزايده بانها قد تشارك في نوع من
الاجلائي او انقاذ الرعايه الغربيه
المحاصرين في البلاد واضافت الصحيفه ان
مسؤولين بريطانيين تذاكروا ان وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه منخرطه ايضا في تخطيط
حكيم لكنها لم تعلق بخلاف ذلك على الاجراء
الذي قد تكون المملكه المتحده على استعداد
الاتخاذه في موقف متغير وربما خطير وقالت
بمصادر العسكريه بريطانيه اخرى ان بعض
الوحدات تجهز اذا دعت الحاجه اليها لكن من
شبه المؤكد ان اي عمل قد تشارك فيه
المملكه المتحده ودول اخرى سيجري
بالاشتراك مع الولايات المتحده وافادت
قناه سكاي نيوز بان بريطانيا تضع قوات
وطائرات في وضع استعداد بقاعده عسكريه في
الخارج في حاله الحاجه اليها لاجلاء موظف
السفاره والرعايه البريطانيين من السودان